dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly jhana if I hear now
I'll eat my head if this is going to be
two minutes but I really hope you fellow
scholars are going to like this little
discussion neil degrasse tyson described
a cool thought experiment in one of his
talks he mentioned that the difference
of the human and the monkey DNA is
really small a one-digit percentage for
simplicity let's say it is 1% for this
1% difference there's a huge difference
in the intellect of humans and apes the
smartest chimpanzee you can imagine can
do tasks like clapping his hands to a
given simple rhythm or strike a match
compared to the average chimpanzee such
an animal would be an equivalent of
Einstein or John von Neumann he can clap
his hands what is that for humans
children can do that even before they
start studying they can effortlessly do
something that rivals the brightest
minds monkeys could ever produce imagine
if there were a species that is to save
1% difference away from us humans in the
same direction what could they be
capable of their small children would be
composing beautiful symphonies perfect
harmonization for hundreds of
instruments or they would be deriving
everything in the history of physics
from Newton's laws to quantum
electrodynamics and their parents would
be like oh look at what Little Jimmy did
that's adorable and they would put it on
the fridge with a magnet just like we do
with the adorable little scribbles of
our children just thinking about the
possibilities gives me chills now let's
transition into neural networks an
artificial neural network is a crude
approximation of the human brain that we
can simulate on a computer to recognize
images paint in the style of famous
artists or learn to play video games and
a number of different very useful things
the number of connections that we can
simulate on a graphical card of our
computer grows closely to what's
predicted in Moore's Law which means
that the computing capacity that we have
in our home computers doubles every few
years it's pretty crazy if you think
about it but most of you fellow scholars
have phones in your pockets that have
more computing capacity than NASA had to
land on the moon
as years go by there will be more and
more connections in these artificial
neural networks and they don't have to
adhere to stringent constraints like our
brains do such as fitting into the human
cranium a computer can be the size of a
building or even bigger computers also
transmit data with the speed of light
which is way faster than the transfer
capabilities of the human brain Nick
Bostrom asked a lot of leading AI
researchers on the speed of progress in
this field and the conclusion of the
study was basically that the question is
not can we achieve human-level
intelligence but when we will achieve it
however the number of connections is not
everything as an artificial neural
network is by far not a 1:1 copy of the
human brain we need something more than
this a very promising possible next
frontier to conquer is called recursive
self-improvement recursive
self-improvement means that we tell the
program to instead of work on an
ordinary task like do better image
recognition we would order it to work on
improving its own intelligence ask the
program itself to rewrite its code to be
more efficient and more general so we
have a program with a ton of
computational resources working on
getting smarter and as it suddenly gets
just a bit smarter we then have a
smarter machine than can again be asked
to improve its own intelligence but it
is now more capable of doing that
therefore if we do this many times leaps
are going to get bigger and bigger as an
intelligent mind can do more to improve
itself than an insect can this way we
may end up with an intelligence
explosion which means a possible
exponential increase in capabilities and
if this is the case talking about human
level intelligence is completely
irrelevant during this process given
enough resources the system may go from
the intelligence of an insect to
something way beyond the capabilities of
the most intelligent person who ever
lived
in about a second or less it would come
up with way better solutions in
milliseconds than anything you've seen
on to minute papers and there's plenty
of brilliant works out there and of
course it could also develop
never-before-seen super weapons to
unleash an unprecedented destruction on
earth we wouldn't know if it would do it
but it is capable of doing that which is
quite alarming I am not surprised that
Elon Musk compares creating an
artificial superintelligence to
summoning the demon and he offered ten
million dollars to research a safe way
to develop this technology which is
obviously not nearly enough but it is an
excellent way to raise awareness now the
classical argument on how to curb such a
superintelligence if one recognizes that
it is up to no good people say that well
I'll unplug it or maybe lock it away
from the internet the problem is that
people assume that they can do it we
can't lock it up in any way we can think
of but there's only so much we can do
because as Neil deGrasse Tyson argued
even the smartest human who ever lived
would be a blabbering drooling idiot
compared to such an intelligence how
easy is it for a grown adult to fool a
child a piece of cake the intelligence
gap between us and the super
intelligence is more than a thousand
times that it's even more pathetic than
a child or even a dog who tries to fool
us we humans can anticipate threats like
wielding weapons or locking dangerous
animals into cages and so can super
intelligent beings also anticipate our
threats only way better it can trick you
by pretending to be broken and when the
engineer goes there to fix the code the
manipulation can begin it could also
communicate with gravitational waves or
any kind of thing that we cannot even
fathom just as an end has no idea about
our radio waves and we don't need to
characterize super intelligent beings as
an adversary the road to hell is paved
with good intentions it may very well be
possible that we assign it a completely
benign task that anyone could agree with
and it would end up in a disaster in a
way we cannot anticipate imagine
assigning it a task of maximizing the
number of paperclips
nick bostrom argues that it would at
first maybe create better blueprints and
factory lines and after some point it
may run out of resources on earth
then in order to maximize the number of
paper clips it would recognize that
humans contain lots of useful atoms so
eradicating humanity would only be
logical to maximize the number of
paperclips think about another task
creating the best approximation of the
number pi one can approximate to the
most decimals by using more resources to
have more resources one builds more and
bigger computers at some point it runs
out of space and eradicate humans
because they are in the way of creating
more computers or it may eradicate
humans way before that because it knows
that they are capable of shutting you
down
and if you get shut down there's going
to be less digits or paperclips
so again it's only logical to kill them
the task will be done but no one will be
there anymore to say thank you it is a
bit like a movie where there's an
intelligent car and the driver is in a
car-chase situation shouting we're too
slow and fuel is running out please
throw out all excessive useless weights
and along some empty bottles the person
would be subsequently ejected from the
vehicle we don't know what is going to
be the next invention of mankind but we
know what's going to be the last one
artificial superintelligence it has the
potential to either eradicate humanity
or solve all of its problems it is both
the deadliest weapon that will ever
exist and the key to eternal life we
need to be vigilant about the fact that
we have tons of money invested in
artificial intelligence research but
barely any to make sure we are doing it
in a controlled and ethical way this
task needs some of the brightest minds
of our generation and perhaps even the
next one and this needs to happen before
we get there when we are there it's
already too late I highly recommend an
absolutely fantastic article on wait but
why about this or Nick Bostrom's amazing
book super intelligence there are tons
of other reading materials in the
description box for the more curious
fellow scholars out there thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
you